[Musica]
potreste essere tutti d'accordo con me
sul fatto che l'ultimo anno e mezzo è stato
estremamente impegnativo a causa di kobe
19.
essere chiusi in casa a volte con
poco tempo per uscire
non c'è tempo per vedere i propri cari i tuoi
amici
non lavorano non vanno a scuola esso  è stata dura e
ci sentiamo tutti come se fossimo rimasti bloccati
lì per tutta la vita, non solo un
anno e mezzo,
non vediamo l'ora
che finisca,
vogliamo disperatamente un trattamento un
vaccino
vogliamo riavere la nostra libertà
vogliamo vivere di
nuovo una vita normale, giusto
ma se questa fosse la tua vita normale e
se dovessi spendere per dover
trascorrere
un blocco al riparo dagli agenti patogeni per
tutta la tua vita
dal giorno in cui sei nato e se
dovessi spendere questo  blocco per tutta la vita
non a casa tua seduto sul divano a
guardare la
tv che cuoce la pizza ma invece all'interno di un
ospedale
o in una stanza di steroidi o peggio ancora all'interno
di una bolla
questo può sembrare la trama di un film di
fantascienza ma non è
lì  persone reali là fuori
bambini la
cui vita è un blocco infinito senza speranza
questo è david meglio
conosciuto anche come il ragazzo nella bolla
david è nato nel 1971
negli Stati Uniti e ha vissuto tutta la sua vita
solo 12 anni all'interno di una bolla
all'ospedale pediatrico del texas
infatti  davey è nato con una malattia rara
chiamata immunodeficienza combinata grave
o slittamento
che rendeva il suo corpo incapace di combattere
qualsiasi tipo di infezione quindi anche l'
aria che respirava poteva essere letale per lui
e anche il culto più semplice
poteva ucciderlo per non parlare della brama 19.
dalla nascita  David non ha mai toccato
un altro essere umano a mani nude,
inclusa sua madre, e non è mai
uscito dalla bolla
tranne che nelle ultime settimane prima della sua
morte nel 1984.
alza le mani se hai mai sentito parlare di
David o di una scenetta prima d'ora.
pochi di voi ce l'hanno e questo
perchè lo slittamento
è una malattia rara ma ciò che è
raro vi do qualche numero e
qualche esempio
quindi ci sono un centinaio di bambini nati
ogni anno
con lo sci  solo nell'unione europea
non è molto vero è abbastanza raro
il gruppo di immunodeficienza primaria
come la scenetta
comprende 300 diverse malattie che
aumentano il numero di
bambini nati con un
sistema immunitario compromesso
a 50 000 bambini solo in europa
è più alto ma comunque raro
se guardiamo all'insieme delle
malattie rare che colpiscono l'essere umano le
cose si fanno spaventose infatti ci sono
settemila diverse malattie rare che
colpiscono circa 30 milioni
di persone in europa e 350
milioni nel mondo e se pensiamo
su tutti questi 350 milioni
in europa significa che come quasi
tutti i cittadini europei soffrirebbero
di una malattia rara forse avrete sentito parlare di
alcune
di queste malattie di questa malattia rara
emofilia
talassemia fibrosi cistica
sclerosi multipla Il 50 per cento
dei pazienti con una malattia rara sono
bambini
che costituisce quasi 180 milioni
di bambini nel mondo affetti da
una malattia rara
e ti dirò di più  fatti sconvolgenti
le malattie rare sono gravi
progressive e fatali come hai visto
per lo slittamento
infatti le malattie rare sono responsabili di
35 decessi nei bambini entro il primo
anno di vita
e peggio di tutti il 95 percento di questi
bambini
di questi pazienti non ha un
trattamento  a volte non hanno nemmeno
una diagnosi
un terzo dei rari pazienti non ha una
diagnosi
o aspetta in media quattro anni per averne
una accurata
come puoi immaginare questo è un peso non
solo per il paziente stesso
ma anche per la famiglia  i genitori i
tutori
che spesso si sentono impotenti isolati
e le cui domande sono spesso senza risposta
immaginano che a te o ai tuoi cari venga
diagnosticata una malattia così rara
che non esiste una causa nota nessuna
informazione online
nessun trattamento nessun gruppo di supporto a cui rivolgersi per
immaginare di sentirsi come  nessuno può
capire te
e la tua malattia a volte nemmeno i tuoi
medici si stima che una persona su
17 sarà
colpita da una malattia rara a volte  Punto
nella loro vita
come un paziente come un genitore un badante
un amico di un paziente raro e solo per
avere un'idea di cosa sto parlando
è come se oggi sei persone in questo pubblico
dovessero affrontare una malattia rara
qualche punto della loro vita
o millequattrocento persone solo
nella città di miranda
e tre milioni e mezzo all'incirca in
italia
e ancora potresti
essere una persona su 17
che non sarà colpita da una malattia rara
a  qualche punto direttamente o indirettamente e
potresti pensare che questo non
ti riguardi affatto,
tuttavia devi sapere che dati gli
effetti devastanti che queste malattie
hanno
pazienti rari hanno bisogno di ricoveri molto frequenti
per ottenere
cure per questi sintomi per ottenere
controlli sanitari esami
e questo  rappresenta un enorme onere per il nostro
sistema sanitario a
cui tutti contribuiamo pagando le
tasse
ogni anno quindi
spero di aver chiarito il mio punto ormai
è che le malattie rare colpiscono ogni
singola persona
in qualche modo ho iniziato  studiando sulle
malattie rare e sui modi per curarle
all'incirca all'età di 22 anni quando ho
avuto per caso il
mio inserimento in un laboratorio di terapia genica
presso l'università di modern
originalia e una cosa che mi ha sempre
affascinato ma mi ha spaventato di più
di questa malattia è  che hanno
un'origine genetica
significa che sono causati da un errore nel
nostro dna
ora potete tutti sapere cos'è il dna è
il libro della vita
è il libretto di istruzioni del nostro corpo e questo libro
contiene sei miliardi di lettere
e un solo errore in un
solo  la lettera porta a una
grave malattia genetica rara devastante come hai
visto per sbandate
il fatto che la causa principale di queste
malattie
risieda nel dna ha spinto gli scienziati
a trovare modi per curare questo paziente
agendo direttamente sul dna
e questo è qualcosa che io  'ho lavorato
negli ultimi 15 anni,
parlo di terapia genica,
quindi con la terapia genica vogliamo correggere
questo errore nelle cellule staminali del paziente
ma tramite l'ingegnere genetico  Ciò
accade in laboratorio,
quindi in caso di malattie della pelle o rare che
colpiscono il sangue
ciò che facciamo è rimuovere un campione dal
midollo osseo o dal sangue del paziente
e isoliamo le cellule staminali del sangue in
modo che le cellule staminali siano le cellule madri
sono l'elemento costitutivo  di tutti i corpi
le cellule immunitarie e le cellule del sangue quindi
isoliamo queste cellule
e quindi quello che facciamo è cercare di
correggere questo errore introducendo
inducendo una copia corretta di questo
dna che contiene l'errore e provoca
la malattia
all'interno di queste cellule ora armate di  tutte
le istruzioni vitali e questo pezzo di
dna che in precedenza avevano perso
queste cellule possono essere reintrodotte
al paziente dove sarebbero
cresciute e daranno origine a un
sistema immunitario nuovo di zecca e funzionante
e cellule e cellule del sangue e mentre
questi possono sembrare  un approccio futuristico
la terapia genica è una realtà ora
come puoi vedere da questa mappa ci sono
oltre 200 studi clinici di terapia genica in
corso
in questo preciso momento nel mondo e
solo a  il centro dove lavoro il
grande ospedale per bambini di strada del tormento
è uno dei centri leader per la terapia genica
più di 60 pazienti sono stati curati
con successo mediante la
terapia a catena e, cosa interessante,
una delle prime malattie trattate
con la terapia genica è stata un tipo di  skit
david better's disease ed è che
la terapia genica
è in realtà uno dei primi
prodotti di terapia genica
a diventare un farmaco ora
disponibile attraverso il nostro sistema sanitario nazionale
per tutti i bambini affetti da slittamenti
in italia
e nel mondo e come
ulteriore  prova
che il motivo per cui potresti ritenere che questo non si
riferisca a te come non affetto da una malattia rara
in alcun modo ti mostrerò
come questo può effettivamente avere un grande
impatto anche su di te
davvero la terapia genica che inizialmente è
nata
per trattare la genetica rara  malattie
sono state ora applicate con successo per
curare alcuni tipi di cancro
sotto forma di terapia cartesiana ed
è ora una delle
tecniche più promettenti per combattere  una
delle malattie meno rare cancro,
quindi spero di essere stato in grado di convincerti
oggi che il raro
è importante e che ci sono tempi eccitanti
per i pazienti rari per il campo ma anche
per tutti noi
comunque come ti ho detto all'inizio
lì  è ancora una
porzione enorme di malattie rare che sono
senza un trattamento
e anche senza una diagnosi cosa possiamo
fare
per rendere questi trattamenti disponibili a
tutti i pazienti
come possiamo affrontare questa sfida come
possiamo migliorare la vita di questi
bambini di questi pazienti e anche
le loro famiglie
scienziati medici università farmaceutica
noi tutti continuiamo a lottare e lavorare per
trovare nuove cure
e nuovi modi per curare un
numero crescente di
malattie, tuttavia niente di tutto ciò accadrà
se non tutti noi scegliamo di realizzarlo,
quindi come puoi contribuire da oggi
e fare la differenza per i malati rari
ma anche per la salute di tutti noi
prima di tutto prendendo coscienza della
terra comprendendo e riconoscendo che
c'è
davvero un bisogno medico insoddisfatto
secondo diffondendo la voce rendendo
sempre più persone consapevoli del raro
e dell'importanza
di essere rari
terzo credendo e sostenendo la scienza
se puoi donare e sostenere
enti di beneficenza e associazioni che portano
il raro  comunità insieme
e di solito sono quelli che sono
i principali motori e il principale
finanziatore della ricerca scientifica per le malattie rare
se sei una persona sana considera di
donare il tuo sangue
o donare il sangue del cordone ombelicale del tuo
neonato
alla ricerca in modo che più
scienziati apprezzino  io
posso sviluppare nuove cure
considera di iscriverti al
programma di trapianto di birmania
potresti essere uno di quei donatori fiammiferi
per uno di quei pazienti come David
per il quale un trapianto di midollo osseo
potrebbe salvarti la vita
se non puoi praticamente sostenere la scienza
semplicemente
difendilo  sostenitore del
settore della ricerca e dell'istruzione di questo
paese
sostenitore di maggiori risorse da destinare
al mondo accademico r  La ricerca è da qui che la
maggior parte degli studi sulla terapia genica a prova di principio
provengono da
sostenitori dell'assegnazione di più
risorse al nostro sistema sanitario e al personale
sanitario,
ultimo ma non meno importante, nessuno di questi accadrà
finché non cambieremo la nostra mentalità e diventeremo
tutti orientati alla comunità  dobbiamo essere d'accordo sul fatto
che ogni singola malattia, ogni singolo
paziente e la sua malattia
è importante quanto il benessere di
tutti gli altri
e che prendersi cura dei rari e prendersi cura
di
pochi pazienti a lungo termine andrà a
beneficio dell'intera comunità
tutti noi dobbiamo decidere che ogni  vale la pena combattere il
figlio unico anche il più raro
per cui dobbiamo decidere
che tutti contano grazie
[Musica].